this is the level of gaslighting and I
hate that word but but it is but I will
use it when it suits my purposes Chris
Matthews goes to get around for their
professional and political
reasons they've become friends with the
wrong freaking people and these people
are frightening and they want something
Bill and Hillary Clinton M somehow can't
afford a chartered uh plane so they have
to take the charity of Jeffrey Epstein
they want The Prestige of hanging around
a politician would be like me handing
you a menu and then walking over to your
table a few minutes later and going none
of this is food and you go well I don't
understand you go well it's just words
on a paper none of it suggests we have
any of the food you go wait but it's a
menu saying you've got a steak and
mashed potatoes yeah but have you seen
any of it well no I haven't walked back
into the kitchen well then it doesn't
suggest that we have it